well the cabinet office minister and
chancellor of the duchy of lancaster
steve barkley is with us now hello good
morning thank you for joining us um i
suppose you want to start with an
apology to the british public
uh well um we moved quickly in response
to the vaccine obviously this report has
just come out so we want to look at it
and consider it that's why we've also
got an inquiry to ensure that where
there are lessons to learn we do so but
we followed throughout the scientific
advice
we got the vaccine deployed extremely
quickly we protected our nhs
from the surge of cases but of course if
there are lessons to learn we're keen to
do so keen to start with an apology
though i would have thought oh well no
we followed the scientific advice
we followed the scientific advice we
protected the nhs we took the decisions
based on the evidence before us but of
course we've always said with something
so unprecedented as the pandemic there
will be lessons to learn we're keen to
learn them that's why we've committed to
an inquiry
and that will be the opportunity to look
at what could be done differently and
what lessons we take into the future 20
000 lives needlessly lost because you
didn't lock down a week earlier and you
don't want to apologize well the issue
of the timing of the lockdown was based
on the evidence and the scientific
advice at the time the concern was if
we'd lock down too soon there wouldn't
be a willingness to lock down for a long
period of time now we actually know now
that actually there was a willingness of
the british public to lock down for far
longer than we envisaged but that
reflects the unprecedented nature of the
kobe pandemic the fact that we know with
hindsight different things to what we
knew at the time but it's right okay
that we look
in the inquiry at what lessons there are
to learn
and ensure that we learn from them no
apology that um we were told by the then
health secretary that there was a
protective ring around uh care homes and
we know that that not to be the case
well the decisions were taken on the
evidence and the scientific advice at
the time they were taken to protect the
nhs the understanding of issues such as
asymptomatic infection and how that
spread the disease we now know far more
about that than we did in 2020 at the
start of the pandemic so i think the
question for the inquiry will be what
information did the government have on
something that was unprecedented were
the decisions informed by the science at
the time
and do we now know different things
about the pandemic to what we knew in
february in 2020 and of course we've
learnt a huge amount but we did take
decisions to move quickly that is why
the vaccine was deployed at pace that
was a success that the report recognizes
but this report only obviously came out
at midnight i'm very keen to read it but
we're going to have an inquiry to look
at the lessons to take forward to the
future um
you just took at face value what the
scientists said and didn't challenge
them no i think there was rigorous
debate within government with uh science
but of course it was unprecedented so it
was a developing picture for the
scientists themselves there were areas
where i think the government has
received credit for moving very quickly
such as with the vaccine uh deployment
we also move very quickly to protect the
nhs we all recall the scenes in italy
where its health service came under
massive strain
and we were very keen to avoid our own
earlier for reasons we were very keen to
avoid that happening to nhs but of
course well it was an unprecedented
pandemic
we were learning about it as we went
through and of course with hindsight
there's things we know about it now that
we didn't know at the time but we'll
look at the report from the health
select committee and see what lessons
can be taken from suppose my viewers
this morning will find it difficult to
comprehend that you sent
care home residents back
to their care homes from hospital when
you knew that they had covered and you
didn't test
care home workers well as i say we're
going to have an inquiry to look at the
lessons
the principal concern the principal
concern at the time was around the surge
of patients on the nhs the concern
uh around delayed discharge
and how that would block up the capacity
of the nhs the understanding around
asymmetric infection was very different
we didn't have the testing regime that
we now have that had to be built from a
standing start so of course k there are
going to be lessons to learn that's why
we've committed
to an inquiry but the government took
decisions at the time based on the
scientific advice it received but those
scientists themselves were operating in
a very new environment where they
themselves were learning about the
pandemic i don't understand why you
don't want to apologize well there are
lessons to learn but the point is that
we took decisions based on the science
we protected the nhs we got the vaccine
deployed at pace but we accept whether
our lessons
were keen to do so yeah but you're
representing the government this morning
and there were 20 000 unnecessary deaths
in the united kingdom many of them
elderly people and you don't want to
apologize what i'm saying kay is did we
take decisions based on the scientific
evidence we were protected what did we
say
did we save lives through deploying the
vaccine at pace far quicker than many
comparable countries did we protect the
nhs from the surge uh that had
overwhelmed other health systems yes we
did now were there consequences to those
decisions
and what was the scientific advice we
received and did we make the right
decisions these are legitimate questions
for the inquiry to get into the report
you're talking about came out at
midnight i've not had an opportunity to
read it i'm keen to do so but this is
why we have committed to inquiry so we
can get the lesson but on that one fact
20 000 needless deaths according to the
report you don't need to go through the
whole you know hefty report in order to
know that they it says that 20 000
people died needlessly many of them
elderly and infirm
are you not sorry about that well this
is why we're taking decisions for
example around social care
well there will be lessons and of course
where there's lessons we're keen to take
that on board the question you're asking
is in february march of 2020 did we make
logical decisions based on the advice we
received and the knowledge we had at
that point on things like
asymptomatic infections was very
different to what we know now now we've
taken on board those lessons that's why
for example we've said that
people need to be vaccinated if they're
working in social care it's why
throughout the pandemic we had funding
packages of support such as the
infection prevention control that went
into social care is why for example we
applied 11 000 ipads so we could get
better data on exactly what was
happening within the social care sector
but the fundamental point within your
question is are there lessons for us to
learn from what happened at the pandemic
and the answer to that is we will learn
the lessons that's not my question with
respect what i'm saying is that 20 000
families watching this morning probably
lost a loved one uh they couldn't go to
the funerals because either they weren't
allowed at all or that there was an
extended family and they couldn't all go
and we saw
a young man who was lowered into the
ground and his family couldn't be there
and they had to watch it on zoom um 20
000 times that happened needlessly
how can you not say you're sorry well
that is heartbreaking that impact on
families that impact uh in terms of
people's humans is heartbreaking and i
think all of us feel that all of us have
friends and neighbors uh who were in
that situation i think in terms of the
decisions that the government take which
is what this report is referring to
there were decisions we took on the
vaccines to protect the nhs based on the
knowledge we had at that point which
were logical decisions for the
government to take but we're keen to
learn from that period it was an
unprecedented time we were working with
imperfect information and it's important
we take those inquiries and that's why
we've got an inquiry to look at that and
was it logical to spend 37 billion
pounds on a test and trace system that
didn't work well just a minute ago you
were saying that we should have done
more to understand asymmetric testing
that will
no doubt be one of the factors in terms
of what happened in social care because
it was the asymptomatic infections that
played such a big part in the fatalities
that we saw in the social care sector
that is exactly why from a standing
style we built a test and taste capacity
obviously that took a huge amount of
effort and cost indeed it did a huge
amount of cost but on the one saying it
was
is are they just basically um you know
coming up with this report with 2020
hindsight did it easy for them to say
well firstly
the report came out at midnight so
another chance to read it so obviously i
will need to do so secondly i think if
you speak to the leading medical advice
in that country they will not say that
test and trace was pointless in fact
they will say it's a key part of our
armory in terms of which is what i'm
putting to you
i'm saying if you speak to the chief
medical officer if you speak to the
leading medics within our country they
will not say that test and trace is
pointless they will say it is an
important part of the uk's controls
against a repeat of what happened in our
care homes you can't on the one hand say
that we were wrong not to have controls
around people going into care homes and
on the same time say that we were wrong
to put in control i'm not saying
this is what the report is i'm just
pointing to what i'm saying
in the question between on the one hand
saying it's wrong so you're saying that
the report um
is is benefiting from 2020 well the
report came out at midnight i've not had
a chance no but you knew you robbed me
this morning so i'm sure i'm sure that
your aides have pointed out the
highlights for you so well i'm keen to
read it i know we will engage with it
and the inquiry i'm sure will consider
the points that are in it what you're
saying is that the report thinks that
test and trace is pointless that is not
what they said was it was 37 billion
pounds was a waste but it was hugely
expensive and as a former treasury
minister i absolutely recognized it was
very expensive but value for money at a
time a national crisis changes and we
were doing everything we could in order
to put in controls so we could better
protect people and learn from the early
lessons of the pandemic okay let's let's
move on to brexit should we an area that
you know an awful lot about um
the eu it would appear actually uh
giving in and on offering up some
changes that they say they have been
working on for some time to try and sort
out the log jam with the northern
ireland protocol to make trade easier
lord frost giving a speech in lisbon i
think later on today saying it's not
good enough we've not actually heard
what they're going to say yet well he's
giving a speech obviously um i don't
want to preempt that but i don't see it
as the eu giving it or one side giving
it i think there's a recognition on both
sides that the protocol needs to work
for both communities in northern ireland
the whole underpinning of the good
friday agreement which both sides are
deeply committed to is based on the
consent of both communities and i think
there's a recognition on both sides that
the protocol is not working and so what
little trust we'll be talking about is
very sensible proposals that the british
government set out through our command
paper
as to how we can better
ensure that the protocol is fit for the
purpose and sustainable in a long-term
way is it trade that we're worried about
sausage wars as it's um as it's been uh
used as shorthand in in many of the
newspapers or is it uh the involvement
of uh the european courts them
overseeing the protocols in in northern
ireland that we're most concerned about
as a country well it's both i think the
governance because we were told it was
trade wars for a long time weren't we
and now we're hearing about the european
court no it's both i think it's it's
both in terms of how trade and
businesses are affected but it's also
the governance as well and the imbalance
of that
but more fundamentally it's about both
communities
viewing the protocol as sustainable in
the long term and i think that's the
issue because that really goes back to
what i think shapes the views of both
sides both sides are committed to the
good friday agreement both sides want to
ensure that that is protected and we
need a protocol that is sustainable in
the long term and that's really what
lord frost will be addressing today and
just a quick thought i know you've got
to go um
quite a few um supermarkets and food
production companies are warning that
people shouldn't panic buy and uh there
are some concerns about what's going to
happen ahead of christmas and the
shelves are going to be empty in
supermarkets i suppose you would
reiterate their comments that right i
would i would and i think people should
just remember the start of the pandemic
when our supply chains came along with a
huge strain and they saw the resilience
of the uk retail sector the government
is working very closely with industry
reports are dave lewis the chief exec
former chief exec of tesco
into the heart of government to liaise
with the industry we're responding to a
number of industry requests and we do
have an extremely resilient
food sector within the uk and what
happened with petrol was driven by a
consumer reaction there was actually
more uh deliveries than sales going into
full courts that has stabilized but we
are working very actively with industry
and people like dave lewis is helping
with that liaison yeah uh prime minister
enjoying a few days away at the moment
with his young family you must be quite
envious you've not had a break this year
uh well it's quite right the prime
minister given that i think all of your
viewers k would recognize the job of
prime minister is a hugely demanding one
and i think uh people recognize that
it's also important that our leaders our
prime minister uh is able to get
refreshed and come back to the
parliamentary term uh next week i don't
think people will consume that no i'm
not saying that i'm saying you must be a
little tiny bit envious given that
you've not had a break i think the
demands of a prime minister are
extremely hard and it's quite right that
he hasn't read